okay moving on I have to ask you a very
serious question okay how do you like
your bacon yes please just anyway yes
please yes
you do I like it a little chewy really a
little okay yeah it all depends you
could burn mine I'd still be you're like
give it to me no matter how you like
your bacon there is a new spot that has
you covered with 13 Gourmet bacon Styles
Rocky shows us more
you know Las Vegas is already Raider
Nation but as of October we are
officially Bacon Nation as well right
and yes we are all right introduce us to
Bacon Nation how you guys living here uh
we are living large actually Bacon
Nation is a brand new restaurant located
on the second story of The D casino on
Fremont it is a classic diner with a lot
of modern Concepts and a lot of great
puns I am what I ham I love that yes a
lot of great puns uh we are open for
breakfast lunch and dinner 24 hours
right yes yes the late night as well
um all through the night so you can come
great get a great meal any time of day
we also have a space for private events
a private dining room in the back that
can house up to 24 people at any time I
love it so much space for all this food
chef let's talk about the menu what's
the inspiration behind Bacon Nation and
obviously there are meals without bacon
included uh just it was just uh elevated
diner food you know I got French toast
boxes which is filled with all different
types of stuff you got a banana one
right there then we have jalapeno your
poppers which is made by my executive
chef David Maldonado who is a great and
young and talented he got pork belly
Dippers you got a burger and you got a
pasta carbonara which is Abe's favorite
and uh we're just trying to take bacon
to another level and take the food to
another level as well I think you guys
have officially taken bacon to the next
level look at this flight can you talk
about the flavors here yeah so you have
a lemon pepper you have everything bagel
and you have maple and uh it's half inch
bacon and we sell uh we sold over a
thousand pounds last week so a thousand
pounds of bacon yeah and that is
Delicious By the way oh my gosh it's so
good Greg you're also an owner here I
hear there's a special to-go system
right yeah we have a very modern to-go
system individually heated temperature
controlled boxes you will have a QR code
both in bar Canada or your room that you
can scan pay order and then we text you
when it's ready you come down and punch
in your code and off you go with your
food 24 7. Good Eats high tech I'm gonna
go ahead and eat this here what's the
website to get a reservation or more
information for more information go
baconnationlv.com we also have a job
fair on Thursday from 12 to 6. you can
go to the d.com in the Bacon Nation
landing page and get more information on
that I love it I feel like it would be
really fun to work here you guys you
guys have fun here yeah we do we have a
great time all right great fun and great
food I will send it back to you this is
so good